Rusia estaba esperando a los ucranianos
al norte de crimea y resulta que han
vuelto a dar la sorpresa
unas fuerzas del lado ucraniano
Aparentemente se trata de voluntarios
rusos que luchan del lado de kiev han
penetrado en territorio ruso en concreto
en la región de velgot una de las pocas
partes de Rusia que ha sido castigada
por esta guerra desde que empezó la
invasión en febrero del año pasado el
propio gobernador de vélgorón de esta
región rusa ha reconocido que se trataba
de unas fuerzas de Sabotaje y
reconocimiento las que habían ingresado
en territorio Ruso y ahora mismo decía
estaban las fuerzas de seguridad rusas
tratando de expulsarlos del territorio o
destruirlos el presidente Vladimir Putin
ha sido informado de lo sucedido y desde
el kremming argumentan que en realidad
se trata de una operación ucraniana de
distracción para esquivar El golpe
político que supone
la pérdida de bajo mundo